June starts tomorrow I met his men's
health month medical studies show men
are less likely to go to the doctor than
women we were just talking about that
Candace Charles is live at Roseman
University with why it's so important
for guys to get to the doctor Candace
well it's important just like it is for
the ladies you too good morning it's a
good morning folks a simple checkup can
be the beginning of treating and finding
any of those health conditions that
disproportionately impact men now that
includes heart disease suicide and
accidental deaths and of course various
forms of cancer including prostate
cancer which according to the CDC is the
second most common cancer amongst men
one in eight will be diagnosed with it
in their lifetime the reasons why men
are less likely to seek both urgent and
preventative Medical Care vary talking
about the importance of Health Care can
help destigmatize it and encourage the
men in our lives to get the health care
they need and deserve
advantage of every opportunity you can
and that um some things like like
prostate cancer are our best sort of
negotiated by having a discussion with
your doctor about screening and treating
any of those kind of things
that's why it's so important to have a
primary care provider and if you don't
have one now would be the time to go and
look for one coming up I'll have
additional details on what you should be
doing a few steps right now to take
control of your health this June
National men's health month is the month
to do it and of course we got you
covered with details on our website
newsnow.com for now live from Romans
Roseman University Health Sciences I'm
Candace Charles 8 news now Candace thank
you very much make your appointments
today while you're thinking about it
guys